bismarcki has died at the age of 57.
according to tmz the legendary rapper
passed after a series of complications
from diabetes
that he's been fighting for more than a
year back in april 2020
biz was hospitalized due to
complications from type 2 diabetes
and in july 2021 rumors began
circulating that biz had died
however a rep for biz told rolling stone
at the time
the news of bismarck's passing is not
true
biz is still under medical care
surrounded by professionals who are
working hard to provide
the best health care possible
born marcel hall the rapper adopted the
name bismarck key in the mid-80s
gaining recognition for his unique
beatboxing style
and rhymes okay okay okay okay
dubbed the clown prince of hip-hop
marquis rose through the ranks releasing
his most famous song
just a friend off his second studio
album the biz never sleeps
in 1989.
[Music]
[Music]
throughout the years biz has made
countless appearances through film
tv and on stage as a world renowned dj
you